Jenna and Jordan update Jojo and Jordan
update we don't have to be
picture-perfect anymore and catching up
with the bachelor boys that never were
don't forget us it's time for roses and
rose VAE hi everybody I am a lauren zima
thank you for joining us Wow I look
rough today let's just start off with
this I have been dealing with some stuff
guys my mom has been in town and what's
happening in my hair I don't know I
can't address it other than to say I've
been listening to the stars born
soundtrack more and more didn't I feel
myself slowly and intentionally /
unintentionally morphing into Allie so
we will be when the depths now but we're
gonna get to the shallow by the end of
this see you guys like a star is born
let me know because we're here to talk
about bachelor news so why not talk
about the news news are you obsessed
with a soundtrack do you think that the
movie lives up to the hype let me know
but back to the show this week on roses
and Rose day we are getting into
bachelor news you can booze
please drink responsibly you guys we've
been giving you some fun look-back
videos but now we're looking to the
present and ahead what's happening in
bachelor nation let's dive right in I
don't know how to say your youtube name
but so the gross beautiful along with
some other people including Hannah
McGuire wanted updates on the Jenna
Jordan said chana says she can't wait
for Jenna's quote unquote proof to come
out about the text messages so let's
dive into that because it did okay
so Jordan Kim bulb has been a travelin
man you guys drink every time Jordan
goes somewhere different he's been to
Canada
he's hanging out with Daniel McGuire
he's been to Florida he's hanging out
with Demario and Vinnie ooh good for him
get away from all this hubbub you know
but he also did Dancing with the Stars
you're beautiful so putting himself
right in the spotlight with his dear pal
grocery store Joe and you guys know I
loved their friendship on bachelor in
paradise
so this trio was wonderful for me Jordan
dance with them learned the routine in
like a day you guys I mean he did he
knew he was in town but he didn't even
have time to come in for interviews with
us because he was so busy but luckily we
interviewed him at Dancing with the
Stars eights he won't let you down we
got him on the carpet and asked him and
now here was what was crazy just after
Jenna's proof came out was Dancing with
the Stars so we asked him what he
thought of it and here's what he said
but anything that you want to say any
comments that you have
in relation to anything that happened
today no I've already put that behind me
so you killed it tonight so the day of
Jordan being on Dancing with the Stars
Jenna and her team release a report from
a company called protists three which
sounds like a cool futuristic robot and
this company says that it is a forensic
report their slogan is plan protect
prosper the three P's paradise isn't one
of them okay and Jenna and her team say
that this report proves that Jenna did
not send those alleged text messages
that reality Steve published because
they say that the company did a quote
comprehensive forensic examination of
Jenna's devices and that they had some
conclusive findings and this is all a
statement from Jenna scene and that the
report confirmed that those texts that
were on reality Steve's website
definitively did not come from Jenna's
phone here's the deal I don't think
we're going to get definitive answers on
the Jenna Jordan situation unless unless
her team and she move forward with some
kind of legal action against reality
Steve
or maybe if somebody else comes forward
and says no no no I was the person that
could be where we'd get answers but
other than that I think this is just
gonna be coming he said she said at this
point when I talk to Jordan I said
Jordan you have to tell me on the record
if that's what you're saying that you
did not fabricate these text messages
and he said no I did not now Jenna at
first was like I want the truth to come
out and Jordan I are gonna be happy and
I want to get back together with Jordan
but now she is not in that place but
she's also saying that she didn't send
the text it's gonna be a he-said
she-said
I will say that Jenna and Jordan are
both in very existential places let's
just read some of their recent
instagrams Jordan quote we all have a
heart but more importantly we all have
souls is the heart warm bright in the
soul let me know love matched between
the intangible matter within us is rare
in fact most considerate trouble all it
takes is walking in what will walk in
walk in or don't it close the door leave
or claim our ledge Jordan also said on
another insta quote the most impactful
statement of my being in existence is
they quote from Shakespeare's King Lear
quote nothing will come of nothing now
that's the good stuff
well something maybe came of nothing in
this situation I'll say that that's
confusing Jenna also getting very
existential so you know drink every time
one of them is being reflective Janice
said and I quote be strong because
things will get better
it may be stormy now but it never rains
forever smiley face are these song
lyrics I'm sorry winky face
relax your shoulders crown up with your
head held high is this a song please let
me know this is song I don't know you
guys this could be I could be off
someday you'll look back and realize
that your struggles change you for the
better black heart emoji I am finding my
purpose and it's so fulfilling
good great everybody find your purpose
wonderful I'm in for that I just am NOT
in for how confusing this all has been
and again I don't think that we're gonna
get
the answers please let me know what you
guys ultimately think happened here in
the comments also asking for an update
on a different Jordan Jordan Rogers and
Jojo Fletcher
ladies and said who is following Joe Jon
Jordan web series I really love it I
love them together that's some bachelor
news okay so eats he was at the CMT
artists of the Year awards I could not
be there was a Nashville we talked to
Joe Jon Jordan and I made sure did we
ask them about this here's what they
have to say for their new web series I
think everything that people don't get
to see I mean they saw our journey on
the show and then they see Instagram
which is sometimes highlights and
sometimes not our complete life so you
know just the opportunity to share
everything the stuff that we're going
through a rat life moving all the stuff
is going on and Joe Joe and Jordan have
some thoughts on Colton as the bachelor
here they are hopefully he finds love
this time and not trickles through
couple more girls couple more shows some
wonderful they're so sweet looking so
good
I love them both you guys I really think
that they have found a way to make their
relationship last by staying grounded
but involved in the world of bachelor
it's like they know the Colton's the
bachelor they're maybe not watching
every episode they come to events but
they live in Dallas they're doing great
and I think that they're both great let
me know you guys think of their web
series are you watching it tell me by
the way Jojo said that the process of
being the Bachelorette was emotionally
taxing mmm we're gonna have some
behind-the-scenes secrets from bachelor
and bachelorette and bachelor in
paradise world in next week's video if
you guys have questions that you want
answered about what goes on behind the
scenes please leave them in the comments
let me know and I will try to answer
them for you and tell you everything
that I possibly can from all of this
knowledge
so Blake said that he did not want to
campaign to be the bachelor he told me
that but I will say that Blake he's been
making over last time you know he's
really been campaigning out there in no
shade good for Blake you got a make
about Instagram ad money while you can
you gotta do your thing while you can
you gotta capitalize on your moment and
Blake is doing that we have seen ads on
his Instagram including but not limited
to Kahlua okay also Yahoo Sports okay
oh I got an ad for comforters okay and
you know he's like been traveling too
he's in the Nashville hung out with Tia
booth hmm I'm Kaitlyn Bristowe I'm
interested to know who do you guys ship
Blake with now is there somebody else in
bachelor nation who you'd want to see
him with there were rumors he was dating
Christina Schulman he told me that that
was not true but let me know who do you
want to see Blake with because he is
single and ready to mingle per what he
told me in Vegas Jason also been out and
about and doing his thing jason has been
supporting Jordan and Joanne Dancing
with the Stars
he has been hanging out with his Bros if
you guys missed it my interviews with
Jason Blake been Nick and Dean from IR
radio in Vegas are all up at et online
comm they all give their thoughts on
Colton Ben and Nick say that the process
of being The Bachelor it's very
difficult and they say that Colton is
going to be a wreck we'll see him
struggle but then they think it's gonna
be great TV and Dean says the Colton's
gonna be a dumpster fire but he's gonna
watch of course to be a dumpster fire
great great
let's end this on a note of Wow
Jordans next step as he told me is that
he is going to start working as a
motivational speaker everybody
Jordan says quote I hope everyone is
ready for some interior redecorating
mentally I'm ready joy I want to Shea's
lounge in one corner of my brain I want
some cool Mediterranean tile over here
I want ooh a bathroom with double sinks
somewhere in my left cerebral cortex
I would love a nice walk-in closet ooh
with some LED lighting yes please Thank
You Jordan everybody what would you want
Jordan to advise you on please leave
that in the comments below I'd love to
hear what questions you have for Jordan
maybe we can get him some of them anyway
everybody that was bachelor news you can
booze please drink responsibly let me
know how you ultimately feel about the
Jordan Jenna situation it's a he-said
she-said that I don't think we'll ever
get the clear what was said answer to
and let me know what you want to know
about behind the scenes in bachelor
production we are going to pull together
our best interview moments and reveals
and things that I know for our next
episode what questions you guys have
about how everything works leave them in
the comments below and we will answer
them for you as best we can next week
thank you guys so much for watching bye
[Music]
look what I found a hair out of place
that's when the stars weren't sound Jack
if you've been listening to it oh oh I
cried my car a lot anyway